what you can soul is something like this
what's a laptop okay this you can solve
this is an equation so if I assure or
insults and I can find the values of
those protein rules that make it true
the way I do that is with this technique
that you used before factorizing free if
I factorize this left hand time this is
useful to it this is more handy and
here's why
just put your pent-up own equipment if I
tell you I've got two numbers in my head
I've got two numbers in my head okay and
when you multiply these numbers together
these mystery numbers the product of
these two together will just be zero
I'll say that again I've got a mystery
pair of numbers in my head and when I
multiply them the answer is zero okay
without knowing much about the mystery
numbers except why I've just told you
you know that at least one of the
mystery numbers has to be zero does that
make sense right because you can think
of any other numbers you like no matter
what you combine these tweezers you
won't get a product of zero unless the
other number is zero does that make
sense
like there's no combination positive
negative weird no square roots etc one
of zero so how do we go here right do
you see what you got here is a pair of
expressions right here's an expression
every year I'll call it expression one
and here's another one expression two if
you put in a number for X then you'll
just get a number feel like an exercise
hundred this would be 93 in extra hydro
would this be 104 right so you're going
to get two numbers here's my mystery
pair of numbers but what this slide says
is
this one side this one has to be zero so
therefore one of them it has to be zero
as well okay so therefore what I can do
in doubt from here underneath I can draw
an arrow right if this first one X by
the seven if this one is zero then this
equation will be true right I don't
actually care what the other than equal
to so one is this one zero it will be
true alternatively this one could be
zero as well right like if this guy is
zero and now I don't care what this one
is equal to right so one is what is zero
then the other one doesn't matter the
product will still be zero does that
make sense so it's really important that
I have zero everything on the right hand
side okay now have a look at these we
can solve in straight what's X ray to be
equal to this look at once it's just
seven right you add 7 to both sides
what about the other one of the right
hand time maybe is 4
now do you see what happens right if I
put in negative 4 it here and this part
becomes 0 this part will be negative 11
right thank you for by 7 but I don't
care I don't care this negative 11
because negative times 0 is still 0
what if I put in 7 this will be 0 times
11 but I can is 11 because 0 times
anything will still be 0
does that exist so therefore what about
to dance bottom here and here these are
the solutions
okay so just quickly test it out does it
work
can we take seven we take seven let's
pop it back up in here right seven
squared
27 squared 49 7 times 3 it's 21 and then
there's a 28:49 - 21 - 28 sure enough
it's 0 right you can do it with the
other value as well negative 4 what's
negative 4 I'm running out of space
negative 4 squared it's positive 16
negative 3 times negative 4 negative 3
times negative 4 that's plus 12 in it
and then there's a minus 28 hanging on
the end and sure enough it's still zero
okay so do you see we need to don't make
this okay let me give you another
example you're better than this boys I'm
pretty good that's a great question so
the question was does it always have two
numbers to siliceous at the end the
Schreyer is no it depends what kind of
an equation we'll start with I'm going
to show you other type of equations
later on that have different numbers of
solutions like
santa cruz also not only honest with you
okay how long do this was now this was
interesting because it looks simpler but
actually it's a bit trickier I think
anyway okay now have a look it's an
equation so for all equations you've
seen in the past doing the same thing to
both sides is generally a good way to go
so what could you do to both sides you
can take the square root right you take
the square root of this side you get X
if you take square any other side what
do you get you know now I'm sure enough
that is a solution you have solved it
you found values that make the equation
true that's good except we're missing
one there's another value that makes
this true let me show you how we can
find
here's another way of pushing especially
river eyes that you having this zero or
the right hand side is really candy it's
really useful if i want to 0 the right
hand side of this equation this one here
what would I do to both sides so there
you one there right what do i do did he
anyone just try to come both sides okay
so you end up with this this doesn't
look like it's any better but trust me
stay with it look at the left-hand side
when you had an expression over here we
factorized can you factorize daddy yeah
you can write what is it what kind of
factorization is it differences ways you
recognize it into it don't win so I can
write that as X plus nine one one okay
excellent good one
savage okay I've got a factorization
just like my ideas before now I know
what this means
I've got a pair of things they multiply
to give me ur so what is it is to be
zero right okay look at this one this
one is zero what do you get you get done
right this is the one you got before yes
I can order this - not true
negative done yeah so you can see if I
put in negative out in here then it was
alright I'm sure don't you put there you
gotta peel when you square it what you
get for 81 so in fact it's two solutions
there's a positive one there's also a
negative one that's why you shouldn't
think super lazy we're like we're what's
right two numbers when you can write one
so we write plus or minus Laramie